und mir zugeschaltet ist jetzt
rechtsanwalt michael weber er ist
experte für insolvenzrecht guten morgen
herr sippel und an sie die frage warum
hat boris becker so viel ärger mit der
justiz vielleicht können sie uns einen
einblick gewähren wir sind ja alle keine
fach menschen für insolvente also
erstmal einen wunderschönen guten morgen
danke dass ich ihnen die frage
beantworten darf das problem dabei ist
dass wenn man im insolvenzrecht etwas
heiligt verschweigt sowie boris becker
vorgeworfen wird versichert man immer an
die angaben vorher an eigene stadt das
heißt er ist zur wahrheit verpflichtet
zur offenlegung verpflichtet nach der
das nicht drohen dann eben daraus
konsequenzen in strafrechtlichen aber
auch im insolvenzrechtlichen chr wird
muss sich verteidigen muss offenlegen
warum er das getan hat sollte er was er
auch darf natürlich schweigen würde die
daraus folgende konsequenz auswirkungen
auf das insolvenzverfahren haben aber
auch mitunter zu einer haftstrafe
auch in deutschland genau über diese
haft sprache mögliche absprache wollen
wir sprechen ihm drohen ja sieben jahre
haft für wie realistisch halten sie das
ich halte das jetzt nicht so realistisch
dass er die ganze zeit wirklich
tatsächlich ins gefängnis gehen müsste
ich gehe davon aus dass er die über
seine anwälte die gründe darlegen lässt
warum und aus welchen gründen er dazu
keine angaben machen konnte ich gehe
auch davon aus dass das gericht nicht
die härteste strafe dann ansetzen wird
sondern höchstwahrscheinlich mit einer
wird er mit einer geldstrafe
strafrechtlich nicht weiter belangt
werden
nur die insolvenz rechtlichen
konsequenzen daraus sind noch nicht
absehbar denn hier kommt es dann dazu
dass mitunter sogar insgesamt sachen wie
erlass von schulden verkürzung des
verfahrens etc
nicht mehr nicht mehr zu geben zupass
sein werden das heißt er wird daraus
dann eventuell nicht schuldenfrei
rausgehen können sollte das
insolvenzverfahren weiter betrieben wird
und dieses insolvenzverfahren kann ja
jahrelang dauern was kann ihrer ansicht
nach boris becker jetzt helfen was kann
ihn entlasten entlasten ist ja ich will
dich man kennt ja die gründe nicht warum
er sachen verschwiegen hat oder ob der
vorwurf der staatsanwaltschaft auch
tatsächlich zutreffend ist dann muss man
den prozess weiter verfolgen
auch ist nicht bekannt wie seine
verteidigungsstrategie aktuell aussieht
bislang hat er sich ja noch nicht
inhaltlich dazu geäußert es das wird so
ein bisschen der knackpunkt sein wohin
die reise dann auch geht
ich gehe aber stark davon aus dass
vollständige kooperation zu sichern wird
dass er auch angaben zu den
vermögenswerten machen wird damit die
arbeit auch des insolvenzverwalters dann
und des insolvenzgerichts dann in
england weitergeben könne
denn sobald die immobilien in
deutschland liegt wer mit oder
immobilienwerte in deutschland liegen
wer mitunter dann auch über das
europäische insolvenzverfahren dann auch
am noch über ein deutsches gericht dann
etwas zu zügigen also ein kompliziertes
verfahren an dem wir auf jeden fall
dranbleiben rechtsanwalt michael sowie
vielen herzlichen dank für ihre
einschätzungen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren